welcome back to cvs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the volcano
eruption that's been causing havoc on
spain's canary islands for more than a
month now that eruption is taking a toll
on land and under the sea volcanic ash
and lava are covering the seabed
this underwater video shows aquatic life
and habitats covered in ash
roxanna saberi is on the island of la
palma where the volcano continues to
pose a threat to human life as well
roxanna good morning
good morning lava from the volcano has
scorched more than 2 thousand acres so
far including some of the neighborhoods
you see behind me and the eruption shows
no signs of slowing yet
on an island only around 15 miles wide
this volcano is leaving nothing
untouched
from the smoke in the air to the ash
that blankets the cars and the streets
the effects of this volcano are
literally everywhere
maria fuentes and her son airam fled
their home weeks ago with just these
bags
before lava buried and baked their town
now they're on the run again
it's very hard to start over from
scratch she says it's frustrating that
nothing but nature can stop the volcano
the eruption has also destroyed her
livelihood like thousands of others here
she worked on a banana plantation like
this
half the island's economy depends on
this fruit heat and ashes have ruined
much of this year's crop
total destruction maria says
are you afraid
with all this it's normal for us to be
afraid her son says we don't know how
long this will last
many residents here including maria tell
us they love this island and they don't
want to leave they say they're strong in
spirit and together they'll get through
this roxanna seberry cbs news la palma
spain
you remember this playing out in hawaii
just a few years ago and imagine how
nerve-wracking it is living nearby and
in iceland too remember all the smoke
and it really hampered
air travel yeah across europe it's
something and the economic impact on
such a small place is just amazing to
see it's so destructive
but it is amazing to watch it is
fascinating